I first met Bert Roman at the start of
the year he's a hematology nurse and was
striking for better pay and now he's
getting ready to do it again I don't
want to do this
um this is not my job I want to care for
patients and the fact that my government
is not caring for us and for our
patients because I mean indirectly they
also care for the nation that way it's
just letting me down
but a lot has changed since this strike
in January Bert's Union the Royal
College of Nursing has rejected the
government's payoffer while Unison has
accepted the deal for its members now we
have the very real possibility of you
taking strike action coordinated strike
action with Junior doctors that would be
disastrous for the NHS and its patients
are you willing to do that we always try
to minimize the risk as medical
professionals just as firefighters if we
if there is a fire we will come and help
yesterday I was walking over the street
from work and someone fell on the street
so I out of my hours I will still help
and that will still be the case during
strike action so you are willing to take
coordinated strike action even though it
would have this impact on patients we
have to because there is other how how
will we achieve saving the NHS for for
this nation the Specter of coordinator
action will strike dread into patients
trust leaders and the governments that
would be completely unprecedented we
would be in Uncharted Territory if that
were to take place obviously uh it would
be even more challenging to plan for
manage mitigate all of the enormous
challenges that would present the
service with it really is uh deeply
concerning if if that is a scenario we
are facing the government will decide in
early May what it does next are the
unions like the GMB and unite will know
what their members want by then if they
accept the offer that will leave just
the RCN and Junior doctors in opposition
all options are on the table at the
moment but it's in Steve Barkley's power
to prevent all of this happening at the
moment he's offering Junior doctors zero
percent we just want to get him around
the table and we were waiting for Steve
Barkley to provide us with a credible
offer he's not doing that
Bert says he does not want to strike but
feels it's the only way to make the
government listen this time though it
will be different if the strikes are
coordinated the stakes are much higher
oh she's Josh is Sky News in central
London